[Music]
what's up guys Helen here at wisecrack
there's nothing we like more than having
our minds bent by movies whether we're
wrapping our brains around multiple
layers of Dreamland faux reality
witnessing a ballerina totally losing
her sheep or watching a dude explore the
intricacies of indoor plumbing we tend
to absolutely love it when movies turn
our brains into jello and arguably few
films are quite as mind-bending as
Martin Scorsese's 2010 thriller Shutter
Island the film has more twists and
turns than a Chucky Cheese playground
slide but we've always found the reveal
at the end to be more than vaguely
predictable in the late 90s and early
2000s a lot of movies feature to twist
revealing our protagonists or
perspective Fight Club of the beautiful
mind The Machinist identity etc coming
out in 2010 it seemed like shutter
island' was a little late to the party
leaving us at wisecrack wondering is
that all there is to it is this movie as
smart as you'd expect from one of
America's most celebrated filmmakers is
there something deeper going on let's
find out in this wisecrack edition on
shutter island' deeper dumb oh and for
the second time spoilers ahead all right
guys let's do a little recap shutter
island' places us in a creepy mental
institution made creepier by its
convenience isolation from society piece
of eh ton of water
leo plays ugly tie-wearing teddy a US
Marshal investigating the disappearance
of rachel solando
one of the islands dangerous criminal
inmates whose favorite hobbies include
drowning her children and then blacking
out soon we meet the requisites sketchy
psychiatrist including one who's
definitely not so curious when
head-shrink dr. Cawley proves shady and
doesn't cooperate with the investigation
things seem increasingly more sinister
all the while teddy has a ton of trippy
flashbacks reliving the various traumas
of his life ranging from liberating the
Dachau concentration camp to losing his
wife to a fire also turns out that the
guy who started set fire Andrew latest
is at this mental institution and Teddy
wants to track him down
we should name andrew laeddis this whole
mission culminates in him discovering
the real rachel solando hanging out by
an international rat convention claiming
to be a psychiatrist who discovered that
the doctors are using lobotomies and
experiments as part of a top-secret
government program to develop
mind-control techniques
thanks only things are about to get
wilder we find out that teddy is
actually Andrew who became psychotic
after killing his wife because she
killed their three children on top of
that his entire investigation was
actually just an elaborate LARPing
experiment conducted by at the asylum to
help rid teddy I mean Andrew um I'm just
gonna call on teddy okay of his
illusions as a slightly demented form of
role play therapy while presumably also
giving this doctor and patient amateur
acting troupe a chance to show off their
chops Oh also unless Leo acknowledges
the truth about his past and accepts the
totality of his identity he's gonna be
lobotomised he's like hard pass and
heads up to the creepy lighthouse to go
get his brain jiggled by chopsticks the
end even if you've seen shutter island'
that's a topsis might read like your
most ADHD friend trying to get through a
campfire story it's helpful here to
contextualize this movie as an Amash to
high and low brow film noir traditions
film noir was the catch-all phrase for
this special brand of film that
particularly flourished post-world War
two
it featured dark shadows unreliable
narrators weird angled shots and perhaps
most iconic leaf plots that involve
plenty of unexpected twists and dramatic
reveals but maybe aren't a hundred
percent airtight all of the above could
just as easily describe shutter island'
indeed this film is almost pulpy in the
way it purely revels in every no art
trope from the creepy cemetery to the
fantastical dream sequences to the
narrator with the slowly revealed dark
past especially one rooted in world war
ii with mental asylums a looming tall
building in this case a lighthouse
creepy staircases casual semi Nazis and
more the film almost reads like a grab
bag of know our traditions the Scorsese
was deliberately a voguing noir is
important in parsing the film that's
because in general the water films are
less concerned with narrative coherence
than they are with mood atmosphere and
conveying the psychological condition
usually suffering of their protagonists
we're gonna treat shutter island' like a
Noir
and say upfront the narrative plot has a
lot of turns and arguably doesn't add up
but that's almost literally irrelevant
what's more interesting is whether the
film compellingly depicts Teddy's
psychological condition and in the
process reveals anything about us /
humanity at large so with that caveat
let's dive in at its core shutter
island' is about a man who refuses to
acknowledge large swaths of his inner
self and so he creates an alternate
reality scholar Stella broods he
actually compares it to Inception when
she writes that interior T that means
inner character / subjectivity in both
inception and shutter island' is
directly threatening to the protagonists
mental and physical stability the lack
of clarity between layers of
consciousness is a key narrative element
indeed
Teddy's closed himself off from the
traumas of his past and can only reckon
with those memories by dreaming them or
projecting them onto other people's
lives
hence conjuring rachel solando and
latest he's living in a fantasy world
lurking with sinister presumably
imagined threats his disconnection with
his own identity is almost immediately
established in one of the first shots
when we see Teddy examining his own face
in a shaky mirror
he's just puked his guts out suggesting
an inner discordance and inability to
orient himself the mirror perhaps
indicates the duplicity and Harwich his
character a scholar and net warm blood
puts it one might argue that the entire
journey takes place inside the mind on
the other side of the mirror from there
Scorsese uses every tool in his
cinematic toolbox to convey this warped
reality most literally the film employs
an estimated 650 special effects
including blue screen maps digital
painting 3d computer effects and even
digital miniatures while plenty of
movies use a crap ton of special effects
they're generally employed to achieve
visual believability here all of the
special effects work to create a
slightly artificial reality this is
fitting for a movie in which 90% of the
action takes place inside a giant
performative charade undertaken by the
world's most dramatically talented
shrinks it's even more fitting for a
narrative viewed entirely through the
eyes of a man literally living in a
fantasy world examples of this
artificiality include the rear
projection inspired shots of the ocean
and sky behind the boat when the men
arrived at Shutter Island the artificial
lusciousness of this gazebo setting and
the almost absurdly thick dreamlike
layer of fog in the movies opening
shocked at the same time the perspective
is purposefully disjointed with
instances of almost deliberately sloppy
editing like in the boat sequence when
Teddy's partner's mouth is out of sync
with his words until it cuts to a
reverse shot at which point it's
suddenly in sync how long you been with
the marshals for years so you know how
small it is
I thought you you got a girl a similar
effect is achieved in a flashback when
Teddy's wife starts talking before we
see her mouth move followed by another
John cut remember when we stayed in the
cabin in the cemetery she's here you
can't leave here the contrasting use of
jarring angles and succession
along with inaccurate sound syncing
serves to disorient us and rattle our
perspective an imitation of Teddy's
rattled psyche in another instance when
the men are being introduced to the
buildings on the island there's a whip
pan which sloppily hides an editing cut
as if Teddy hesitates for a moment in
keeping up the charade while staring at
familiar buildings all of these
interruptions are entirely intentional
meant to jolt us just as Teddy psyche is
being jolted with memories the sound
design also reflects Teddy's heightened
sense of fear and paranoia sometimes the
sound mix is too loud as with the
initial over-the-top ship noises that
don't coincide with the actual waves
creating a sense of hyper reality
fitting for a character with no grasp on
the truth
other times the sound is unnaturally
quiet as when they're entering Ward C
and we see a lot more rain than we can
hear throughout during moments of high
tension sounds and music are ramped up
beyond mere dramatics from the extreme
introduction to the island
to the thunderstorm that booms after
Teddy gets a disturbing note from one of
the patients other visual elements help
situate us in Teddy's mind as the film's
director of photography Robert
Richardson put it the lighting color and
texture all contribute to the blurring
of reality and hallucination raising the
question of what is subjective versus
objective colors in particular play an
important role from the very beginning
Teddy's false reality on shutter island'
is d saturated and vaguely dismal these
segments are far less vivid than his
fantasies and dreams which take place in
hyper saturated hues inspired by 1950s
era Kodachrome film that they feel hyper
real suggests that Teddy's dream world
is more palpable to him than the world
around him and helps us understand just
how vivid his illusions really are while
much of the present-day scenes are
filled with gloomy grays and blues it
doesn't stay this way the entire movie
the colors become increasingly brighter
almost blinding in moments when Teddy
comes close to discovering the truth or
hasn't encountered that jiggles his
memory crescendoing in this scene which
is filled with pools of light perhaps
literally representing the way the truth
will shine a light on Teddy's delusions
in fact Teddy even walks right into the
light as his doctor delivers the final
blow of reality showing him photos of
his dead children and he falls into a
halo of brightness and collapses after
remembering these painful experiences in
the final scene the grounds of the
asylum are nearly as saturated as his
fantasies suggesting that he is fully or
at least more so present in reality
Scorsese doesn't only rely on the
strength of his own movie to convey this
theme see Chris AZ is a grade-a Phil
nerd and that nerdiness is on full
display and shutter island' the film is
littered with references to other movies
especially film the wars but also other
classics about madness and psychosis
like Suspiria and shock corridor his
clearest influence though is Alfred
Hitchcock who popularized the modern use
of the psychological subjectivity via an
unreliable narrator trope
Scorsese even had his crew watch
Hitchcock's at the wrong man in
preparation for shooting Shutter Island
as the eagle-eyed Guardian writer Andrew
Pulver notes these emojis range from a
shower head spouting water like in
psycho to climbing a narrow stairway
like in vertigo to hanging off of a
cliff like Cary Grant in North by
Northwest to this creative shot of a gun
like it's spellbound to this tree flying
through a wall like in Marni
what's more the use of blue screen matte
paintings is reminiscent of the
technology Hitchcock would use when
situating his characters in unfillable
backgrounds as the film's special
effects supervisor Rob legato put it
there's a fine line between making it
mostly look correct but not all correct
so it has a Hitchcock quality to it
another famous director Stanley Kubrick
gets a shout out to the looming tracking
shots that put us directly in Teddy's
physical movements deliberately evoke a
similar technique the crew Breck
innovatively employed in the shining as
a means of more accurately conveying
subjectivity through cinematography
similarly the choice to use music by one
of Kubrick's favorite composers Georgie
Ligeti also evokes the Masters work we
could spend ages parsing the film for
every reference but we think you get the
point
Scorsese is infusing his film with all
the major cinematic trappings of
subjectivity and unreliable narration to
put us directly in Teddy shoes so
Scorsese is certainly using a lot of
cool techniques to make the movie more
effective but does that mean there's
anything deep there well we think so and
yep we're going meta all of these
devices are actually reinforcing a major
theme of the film that we need to
empathize with people experiencing
mental illness rather than writing them
off as crazy or untreatable
this is dr. Colley's position to begin
with that you should treat patients like
human beings and see them as capable of
growth and improvement even if they've
committed violent crimes just as
Kingsley sees him is sympathetic saying
my job to treat my patients not their
victims I'm not here to judge we to
learn to view them is sympathetic by
seeing the world through an actual
patient's perspective at the beginning
these patients are regarded by the
camera as freaks
spectacles to be viewed from afar and
nervously ignored by the end we've
engaged with many of them as human
beings and most importantly we've been
thrust into teddy subjectivity we've
seen his struggle firsthand thereby
making us recognize his unmistakable
humanity
as a result we know that despite the
whole telling us why think Teddy's are
pretty caring dude with some genuinely
good qualities if we had met Teddy as an
inmate early on we would have regarded
him as merely insane
not unlike teddy does when he first
surveys the islands patience the film
seems to rather blatantly articulate its
thesis statement via this written plaque
at the beginning of the film which reads
remember us for we too have lived loved
and laughed we're forced by nature of
the cinematic experience to sympathize
with people whom society typically
ignores or overlooks cinema is one of
the only art forms that can so palpably
immerse us in someone else's experience
and we think that makes it a pretty
powerful thing and shutter island' a
pretty powerful film but all of this is
in the service of the central question
being posed by the film can you
rehabilitate evil and should you even
try throughout the film
Teddy makes his position very clear evil
is black and white to him he doesn't see
the inmates at shutter island' as worthy
of reformation because they've committed
violent crimes these are all violent
offenders right I mean they've hurt
people murdered them in some cases in
almost all cases yes
and personally doctor I'd have to say
screw their sense of calm he also
refuses to give a dying Nazi a gun so he
can end the pain and he's one of the
first soldiers to start shooting at the
Nazis after the Allies have raided the
camp in contrast dr. Colley makes clear
his opposing view that no person is
beyond redemption or rehabilitation
these two opposing views are complicated
when we learned that Teddy is in fact an
inmate whom Colley is currently
attempting to rehabilitate the film
addresses this question most
compellingly though through its use of
flashbacks to memories that Teddy
can't process without associating from
what the film seems to argue is that
what we consider evil is really just the
sum result of trauma mixed with mental
instability we can recognize that teddy
isn't evil and in doing so have to
question whether anybody really is
except hold the phone
what about Nazis well what makes this
film so interesting is that it isn't so
one-sided on the issue of evil it leaves
us to decide for ourselves Teddy doesn't
reconcile his trauma and suddenly
believe that people can be rehabilitated
quite the opposite instead it seems like
he chooses to be taken to the lighthouse
to be lobotomised which would be worse
he's a good man here he seems to be
explaining his two choices live with the
knowledge of what he's done or
metaphorically died visa be a stick in
his brain while still under the illusion
that he is a good guy
here we see Teddy appearing to affirm
his belief stated throughout the movie
that the violently criminal cannot be
reformed that he is not capable of
change or growing past his mistakes upon
close analysis it becomes pretty clear
that every cinematic element from
fighting to coloring to production
design to cinematography to music use
was carefully chosen in order to serve
the higher themes at work with those
being the subjectivity of film the
nature of insanity the redemptive
potential of the criminal and the very
nature of evil so we're gonna have to
call this film deep and at least deeper
than the deep end of your community
swimming pool but what do you guys think
is shutter island' a Scorsese and
masterpiece or did dude get a little too
caught up in faking hurricanes and
generally felt impressed with his big
twist ending let us know what you think
in the comments thanks to our dope
patrons for supporting the channel and
our podcasts remember to hit that
subscribe button and as always
[Music]